citizens of the reject Nation I've got
something for you nice nice Final
Destination four see I've been doing a
play on words with Final Destination
four really offers a lot Greg they
should have called it found destination
forever 45 final four is it this one
called The Final Destination yeah it is
do you think they thought it was gonna
be the final destination oh no it can
never be the final destination because I
gotta milk it because that would be sad
and this is not because this franchise
has been amazing so far we're really
excited for this one thank you guys for
sticking with us thus far here's the
good news we're doing Final Destination
four today here's the decent news we are
gonna do five but I'm gonna be out of
town for a minute so you might have to
wait a second for it what you can do is
subscribe and then you'll know when it
is there also while you're hitting
buttons like comment let everybody know
how great my four puns are those are all
really important things to do and thank
you so much by the way to prepper for
editing this video If you guys want more
than make sure that you get our full
length Reaction watch along and sync up
with us over on patreon you guys sync up
with your own copy and that's how you do
the thing I finally learned about that
too Greg yeah that's great yeah yeah I
can just tell with how impressed you are
with me and I'm so impressed with you
too Greg mostly because Greg and John
also cover several shows exclusively
over on patreon with reaction highlights
and to watch alongs included are you
ready for this I am for ready forever
ready for fun for final two fun two four
Final Destination yes let's do it
thank you
[Music]
all right in three
two one
four
she's still one two three four yeah that
would have been better it would have
been way better
but sometimes ideas come collectively
yeah that's true
uh what is this one in 3D why do you why
are you saying that because look at the
credits is that how that works this
looks like they wanted this one to be in
3D do we need glasses no no no we we can
see
speak for yourself I need glasses
desperately
Gran Turismo
I I take it this one's gonna be a a
NASCAR wreck which I will say off jump
is the least relatable of all the other
accidents that's true I've only been in
one NASCAR race tell me again why we
chose this overseeing the movie if the
if you guys lose focus spoken a
millisecond you have to scrape them off
the fence what's his name Greg oh my God
please don't do this again
completed of course is to see a crash
you're sick don't do this again her I
know she's from One Tree Hill and also
something else and her name is
Andre this is Sophia no no no no no
she's not Sophia Bush her name is
I know her very well oh
[Laughter]
my God bench Brothers I'm focused on the
movie and not who the cast is
hey sport my girl use your binoculars
well they're not really binoculars
exactly they're more
that's uncouth I owned those oh do you
used to in college and in her 30s I'm
not gonna be able to help it I know both
him and her okay we will look them up
after don't worry pardon me
so annoying I guess it's more relatable
if they die uh our teens
like people die watching sports oh yeah
yeah that's more relatable than dying
playing them that's probably what's
going to happen yeah
[Applause]
tampons in their ears
is that gonna come back around
there goes the neighborhood
[Music]
was that a racist comment I need you to
move your foot thank you
[Music]
I think he's a racist
I think she was in The Flash too or one
of those
motor oil oh death is on its game
Chantal
oh you're still on that I've moved on
is it safe to sit here
what
okay why have all those beloved drivers
died is that common
I guess
there's a crack in the foundation
this just needs to be a cool stun
sequence that's all I want
to wait
yeah yikes maybe go after him yeah run
on the track
kill wall leather
millwall leather is about to make a
leather wall oh everybody's skin gonna
be like everyone going down the tracks
the final is either Crystal or Chantal
shake and bake baby oh oh [__]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
they're like going right to it
oh no that's gonna be brutal no that's
Sharp
[Laughter]
oh no this happens in life yeah you know
if you're in a stampede situation you
want to make sure that you keep your
backpack on
and make yourself as big as possible
you listening to me I could have just
saved your life
this one's super CGI
3D movie
so which one of them do you think is
getting the Visions it's the guy the guy
who got the Beloved yeah that saw the
come on
whoa see that pipe it's in 3D it's right
at me
oh you see the trajectory the characters
go guy girl guy girl cowboy in a hat he
sits here pardon me
she gets tampon she puts him in her kids
ears
it's a lot of tampons for one woman
men are so stupid sometimes
[Laughter]
thank God what no no I got 500.
I want to see the 10 minute short film
where they where they just let it happen
oh we gotta go right now
we didn't spend any time at all getting
to know the characters that's like one
of the build up things you got to do
there's always
wood crash
yeah the security guard is somebody we
know too yeah it's Bubba from Forrest
Gump my wife
[Music]
that's death came for her anyway
oh this is the first time the credits
are after yeah
no that she changed her last name
my new Chantelle Christ a Allen too
interesting okay
this is your bliss right now this is
bliss did you say this is your bliss
yeah I couldn't be happier that I was
right about her name
David Rapaport yes casting let's go
David and Lindsay I love them this isn't
an audition Roxy
oh I think these are deaths from the
older movies
yeah yeah these are definitely other
ones what gave away the train yeah
by caffeine all right challenge accepted
our Amusement Park's going the way of
the dinosaur did you see that sign that
was an Easter egg that was the subtitle
on screen because of what happened last
time yeah but why are we still alive who
cares why if we made it we deserved it
he's my favorite character keep him
alive I think you're as well
oh
McKinley Speedway McKinley McKinley is
the name of the high school yeah yeah
and the guy I can't go back there Lori
yeah screw that I mean the least we can
do is pay our respects to those people
the people people didn't have a doctor
Xavier with them to tell him to get out
of the way it's an X-Men reference good
one kiss it it's your choice heads or
tails but you know I like head
[Laughter]
something gave us a second chance so
this feels like a CW Show yeah it really
does it's giving Riverdale like the line
about had underrated though his
one-liners so far about tampons and
underrated
yes yes
I think they're excellent you've been
able to gather the scope of that line
about it to qualify it as not enough
people have talked about this line yes
you heard me
that kid whoo
you know what I like about this one so
far they're just like let's just go
through all the [__] they know how
this goes speed it up yeah I think
that's a problem we don't need to build
up here I wanted to thank you
you're a hero
because of your warning we're alive and
our two sons are safe look is she tampon
on the ears lady
how did you know what was going to
happen look we're just glad you all are
okay
thank you the music is the dramatic hey
it's it's nice to see people actually
being like hey you're a hero instead of
what are you pretty freaked out about
that back there
I just wanted to ask you how you uh
killed my wife okay okay there it is
like the McKinley dude we need that
character to go in there after but you
uh
I'm sorry for your loss oh he was
getting racist earlier right yeah yeah
nobody lives forever
whoa
it's time for you to leave sir
times
damn koi genre could have played that
guy based on
oh nothing
that was the most disparaging
where do I know the this detective guy
from Bubba from Forrest Gump no I know
him from something have you not seen
Forest no I have I know I'm from a TV
show third the third watch here's a Josh
Third Watch it's an NBC show
whoa It's coming right at me okay I know
the problem that happened with this
movie they made it too much for 3D and
they got way too caught up in the
gimmick this seemed real
relaxing about
doing it right here this franchise is
good at hot people though
sign
it's been a long time since I've watched
a movie where I heard somebody call
somebody the n-word that was like just
truly shocking yeah it was have you
heard uh koi casts McCoy genre
quickest ways to make an audience
dislike somebody depending on who that
audience members yeah I guess the Right
audience hey Ma it's late what are you
doing up
no no no say turn on the TV yeah it's
fine
Alcoholics Anonymous
and the wisdom to know the difference
have we had any hints about how the guy
inside is gonna die
no Red Cross is he like a KKK member
maybe he's gonna die right now I hope we
kill him off early
but does he deserve it Roxy
yes oh okay
he's digging a grave from
no to put the cross in there better
don't you know how it goes
oh oh
maybe death wasn't supposed to kill yeah
yeah maybe death is Against Racism
like this is the first time we're seeing
death be like nobody isn't his time
it's your time
what the hell is happening
he was trying to kill somebody else but
that person wasn't supposed to die yet
you gotta catch on fire
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
damn yo this one is so weird
when you're something freaky ironic
I've seen that door before you have that
is freaky yeah in his nighttime vision
his nightmare you caught that
it's coming right at me this is like
acting out of a late night Cinemax movie
I don't think it was a dream
it was like a vision
I mean there were their flames and bad
continuity I was just saying the same
thing like you can't just imagine her
mouth come on man prepper does a better
job yeah prepper it was like I saw Clues
as to how he was gonna die
just now I saw another one
what is with the continuity Hunter looks
so they can't match it up ever since I
left the racetrack I feel like there's
something in the room with me
this sword is so B movie schlocky
I be lying if I said I wasn't enjoying
it
I bet you can't hit that song with rock
okay oh these are the two kids with the
tampons
all right death let's see what you do
gasoline smoking a cigarette this guy's
an idiot Richard's out today so my
appointment is there someone else that
can see me please
um look at this ah thank you so much
didn't she go on a date with Joey once
When Rachel and he was trying to after
Rachel and him had their friend date and
he started falling in love with her and
then didn't go on a date with her and he
like turned to look at her watch her
walk away and he's like nah
you're not a friend
long enough oh
I've only told him to fix it like I'm
really fine
hey
oh no oh I don't want to watch until it
happens like that
they do know how to do that yeah like
set you up for something disgusting yeah
I already wanna hear it
oh boy
no Nails oh that is the worst second
would be teeth yeah
yeah it's gonna fall
honestly I'm okay with being the fan the
grease whatever but not the toe the
toenail is gross
do you think
see I don't like this stuff where it
just looks like death is just moving
[__] with its hand oh it's sliding on
the water
is it though it looks it kind of just
looks like death is pushing it
honestly seriously as long as it's not
the toe yeah I could watch anything stab
her eyes for all I care
oh
Sizzle sizzle
[Music]
I'm so sorry it won't happen again over
to a different chair
oh is this just one giant fake out
sorry about this boys come on
oh no let's go she's gonna walk outside
and the rock is gonna hit her
you think so yeah you're right
whoa
I on YouTube as long as it's not a
toenail don't you think it's just a
little weird that two of the people Nick
saved are now dead weird is putting
tampons in your kids ears the night
before it happened Nick had a really
strange dream I feel like I'm just
watching a series of events I'm not
watching an actual movie right now
and I realized that I actually seen how
the next person was gonna die we stayed
up Googling premonitions Vision signs
there are tons of articles about people
every Survivor died
and the precise order they were meant to
die in the accident but we survived
so now does that mean we all die you're
catching on sweetheart this feels like a
really well-lit student film
is it really well lit I mean I'm saying
if this was a student film I'd be like
this is well lit and that would be my
compliment I'm just saying he could be
watching a ton of TV you know what this
stuff does to me Janet it's okay what
does it do to you makes her very anxious
Greg why do you gotta be a prick all the
time she saw somebody die right in front
of her so did we yeah and we're all
freaked out
really you you seem so unaffected if
you're right about this whole crash
thing then I'm going to make the most of
every moment I have left I'm gonna go
get laid
if I'm dying I'm trying his lines are
saving this whole movie if I'm dying I'm
trying
probably just some weird coincidence
this guy's way too chill if you're dying
you're trying at least hook up
what does it keep saying in there it's
here
how we gotta go to the racetrack
the way the Visions are shot this time
that 3D thing is just not Landing it's
not creative the way they're doing it
it's it's just like he just has a vision
of how it's going to go down and there's
no like solving you know this is the
only thing that I can think of to help
me remember the order
okay so he he's figured out the order
such all right you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna focus on
what's good about it
watch this happen what's good about it
is looking people yes
dimples
and that racist and his wife we killed
the racist you killed the racists or his
tick tocks as we unalived the races
maybe this was a really bad idea
no no I gotta try yeah you've got
you better have a damn good reason for
trespassing I just need to remember the
order
young man that sounds crazy yep maybe
this will help you did you just say
young man that sounds crazy maybe this
will help you
McKinley Speedway was there any McKinley
in the first two there I have no clue
that's for that guy in the mechanic
jacket dies
Adam Sandler light
that collapse kills hunting Janet
and that's when you die
and then Lori and me
man they got such a high like he's such
a great actor they got him to be in this
maybe if we can stop this mechanic from
getting killed we can break the chain
and the rest of us will all be safe
no negative no his name we know nothing
about him but we do know where he works
Grand State custom yeah smarty
tell me they have her in heels I pray to
God they have her in heels
well what are you doing
trying to find you you think this guy
looks like Adam Sandler yes you don't no
they're now dead
I'm sorry
looks like his brother
[Music]
[Applause]
Emma said it's porno acting well you
literally already said that
oh I did did I Cinemax after dark oh
yeah yeah I did watch it naughty die
like in front of me
I want to see her feet
I lost my wife and my daughter in a car
accident and he escaped death I was
drunk he escaped death today I asked
myself how come it couldn't be me oh he
caused death I was actually destroying
their memory so now I try to live each
day in their name
that's the stuff you don't like
this this this this thing is pace so
weird I'm around dangerous equipment
every day if I was meant to die would
have happened by now
um
I guess it's not my turn to die
whoa that was gnarly cool oh looks like
cake
we have to warn your friends which one
is next look they both die in the
collapse I don't know think Focus I
really feel like this is the first time
they cast people off of their looks or
do you think it's just the directing not
being able I mean I've seen her in
several things and she's she's so good
okay so it could just say it all right
and like honestly struggling with that
because she's really effing talented
this movie is a market improvement over
the last three no we've got boobies in
all movies I don't know about all of
them but this one and last one this is
like an 80s horror sequel
is he a lifeguard no
maybe I don't think so lifeguards were
red right he's your type that's actually
the rudest thing you ever said to me and
so categorically false
laughs
the other guy's more my type
that was so fast it's almost as if I hit
a trigger point God damn it I win that
Mom
thanks have a nice day
let's see what we got here brownie I
swear to God if anything happens to that
dog Penny that's some [__]
that's like a that was huge
close your door yeah
wait don't look up you're driving
what are you trying to do
my custom piece of [__] you're driving
honey what are you trying to do
it's red light
red light red light
red light
clear clear oh damn that's an Easter egg
[Music]
all right
listen to me buddy listen no water okay
stay away from water how can you stay
away from water when he's having sex at
the pool I know I mean this is a death
or thrisking right I mean come on yeah
if I'm dying I'm trying I mean he's
succeeding messages marked urgent
give me the gun oh no this is the man
you said was my type and I'm right
Greg take it back no no no no no no no
don't kill him off he's the best part of
the movie
he he does have the best one-liners
oh
wow that's how you drain the pool that's
a strong strong plastic gun right there
death had to pull on gravity in that
moment
he's always doing this coin thing I know
it's one of his ticks he's a character
actor oh people are always so afraid of
the pool drains
I wonder
oh what's gonna happen it's time to make
some predictions Roxy what's gonna
happen yeah suction to it and drown I
don't know how
Car Wash death do you that I think car
washes are like the hottest place on the
planet I hope you know I I thought you
might have thought
obviously it's for people's minds go is
that true no who the hell thinks that I
don't know sometimes when you're in
there and it's like all the colors and
stuff I'm like oh
yes this is the most seductive place
right here I kind of think so
okay please at home tell me I'm right
let's see if this prays in any fears
because I do like to go to the car wash
I do too because it's hot it's the
hottest place on the planet man you
don't think this is sexy I guess it's
like loud I don't know
what is your qualifications
it's dark it's mysterious it's wet
what is she honking at uh she's trying
to get the attention of uh person there
I'm gonna give the movie credit there I
would have honked the horse try to open
her door why are you trying to open your
door so you can get out of the situation
Car Wash you can't
is she gonna drown in her own car
I mean that's hot to some people man
pure sex oh my gosh you know I see it
now
and I will be yo
where are we now
oh okay obviously a country club Greg
oh it's coin what's gonna happen to get
sucked in there yeah he goes to get it
and he gets sucked in yeah he's gonna
drown him why is this coin have so much
meaning to him I don't know what he's
gonna go try to get it
it went down there oh don't do that yep
knew it I called that take your pants
off take your shorts off take your
shorts off or it could just drown
I feel like she could have climbed out
of there yeah me too maybe it's gonna
close on her head
oh yeah oh now it's moving
oh that sucks yeah that is a good one
that sucks
oh Jesus
would that hurt
it was a well done one
get her out oh no oh no what's gonna
happen
oh she wasn't next I know
take your shorts off because he's your
type that's why I want you to your
shirts take your shorts off
it just like sucked him in yeah that was
a little bit of a stretch
all of him
I'm next George you can't give up unless
you do she was good in other things I'm
telling you
enjoy that one no he's an alcoholic oh
geez Roxy
who's the racist now
I forgot he was reading it my bad I was
just like yeah we could use a good glass
of wine Honestly though if you're an
alcoholic and you know for sure you're
gonna die oh man dude do some coke man
just do it all at this point it's not my
actual suggestion
care what happens we are in this
together this feels like when a director
casts himself in something and that's
why they got this kind of lead that'd be
unique
uh
yes they were saved through action they
were saved does it that's it no this is
action on potholes no through action
they were saved with the parts that were
in the knots filled on oh I think yeah I
caught that too
reaction car washes are sexy yo am I
right or am I right
cheerleaders are at car washes or
something bikini while she's talking
about it's a regular dress every time
I'm in there by myself I'm like I wish
somebody was in here with me man
oh no no George you're the best actor in
the film man come on
providing weight I really don't think
this is the actor's prom fault I think
he's the best one in the film George
no I knew it George I didn't say it out
loud but I knew it oh my God oh my God
a bottle of painkillers I just threw
them up then I went to the garage hooked
the hose from the tailpipe stuck it
inside the car the car kept rolling he's
not next saving Janet must have
destroyed the list then no
I think congratulations are in order and
theoretically is a cool shot we've been
given a second chance
you guys going to do with it they miss
you
this one is so goofy maybe it's time to
stop talking about doing stuff and
actually start doing it through action I
live once right no he forgot about
somebody else's death who could it be
it's like they don't care at all about
their friend that died in the pool in
all fairness I guess they're not
positive it was him they must have
learned by now Amsterdam here we go you
know Janet is so incredibly jealous all
right well tell her I said hi I will
this movie is completely void of
emotions I'm I am curious where we're
going
you are that's a genuine feeling you're
having yeah okay
oh my God Satan
the unknown survivor of the McKinley
Speedway crash has finally been named
Jonathan Groves was rescued in the
rubble
he's next that's the light reason
remember that guy who sat in front of me
in the racing with the cowboy you didn't
die all right which means he's next but
just be there in five all right I'm on
my way did a completely different team
make this movie so he sees him die in
the shower
or this
you feeling okay Mr suvi you know how
many of your kind I killed in Korea I'm
Chinese
pt3 right now okay and I do mean that
okay there's a strange racist Spirit
about this one yeah it's like
unnecessary
[Music]
oh somebody help is it so we don't care
when he dies that they made him racist
also I guess that might be the
best I think they're trying to add
personalities oh but so he's above them
yeah I don't think the old guy's gonna
die
it would be that would be so confusing
like what is happening I made it out of
the rubble and now
you know you guys warned us
I'm waiting for like something to be new
and Innovative like how they figure out
how the person you know how we had like
the photos from the last time or there
was the connection the time before to
the first movie like we need something
hit us with something I think we just
keep an eye out for any signs in danger
I think we got a shot okay let's just go
find Lori and Janet it's like deja vu my
wife say that Deja Vu was like God
okay no
oh
nice five
it is shocking how much of a downgrading
quality of store of of a movie it is I
have like 80 theories on how and why
yeah shoelace that [__] is stuck her
kicks are stuck but she's not supposed
to be sneaks or stuff shoelaces stuck oh
oh help me get it out take your shoe off
okay green screen
what is she next pushing my ankle out
you okay
Nick's gonna think you're so
unattractive now yeah your sneaks are
totally destroyed
where are we that that was just a fire
in the sand I don't know I feel like
they cut to a lot of random spots
theater 13 second toe on your left 13's
an unlucky number for many people it's
only the three of them left yeah and I
haven't given a [__] about anyone yeah
where is um Tony Todd
yes it wasn't even around the last one
it's here
oh my God I think that they're gonna die
in the theater what gave you that clue
well I could pick up on subtle details
really well
oh is this like a happening above the
theater
remember the nail gun death another one
or the nails through that person's head
that was gnarly
the deaths in this one been death by
water in the pool hey man you might be
onto something with the elements you
know honestly the elements came back you
might be honest I thought you would yeah
dude you're on dude now cut them off
what are they watching
[Music]
I was like an AMC commercial whoa
whoa
this is a weird advertisement do you
remember when Nick said that he could
see signs before something bad was gonna
happen now I think I'm seeing them it's
just so Hollow it's like even if I
didn't believe my friend if they said
that I'd be like let's go home this is a
movie who cares really I'd be like we
covered all this time and money
I feel like you drive home Roxy you make
us sit on the aisle anyway oh boy that's
the difference between me and you Greg
that and the whole car washed the buckle
who are you in here Nick
oh good she's right there George is dead
damn it we gotta go come on no wait I
was meant to see this movie
[Laughter]
yeah you are you were but how could she
have died next that really defeats the
order why why who was supposed to die
next Chantal really yeah because we
skipped her already when she was in the
water from the her car right we skipped
her after she was already supposed to
die she got crushed at the same time as
her boyfriend then they were both in
those water accidents but we saved her
from the water accident so we're
supposed to skip her
I'm on your side
there's a lot of massacres in this one
foreign
that's that's different that's Creative
Murder her
oh my God Crusher
flatten her
that means Deja Vu my wife said that
Deja Vu is like God's way
all right I'll give the movie some
credit man that was good that was good
but we're gonna do that whole thing
I mean he's gonna prevent this but
goodbye I didn't think that was did you
see that coming but what I I don't
really get I don't really get it oh okay
just
give me something I feel good whatever
what I'm taking my wins at this moment
I'm playing buddy
why'd you call the fire department man
why don't you call the fire department
damn it
foreign
I think he should have been the first
one to die now they don't care about the
order
oh where's that one thing gonna fly to
We Didn't Start the Fire Fall Out Boy
thank you
you can get out of that
oh I want to see him fail
yeah it's kind of hard to tell who I'm
rooting for I want to see them all die
oh my God it's like it's right it's
Friday coming right at me
fire alarm or what I've been thinking
about what I'm gonna eat after this
movie is done the whole time
what are you thinking my Lean Cuisine
Pizza
oh my God he saved the day
two weeks later isn't it supposed to be
screwed tighter
you're right tell you what we'll get
somebody on that pays to be safe man
trust me
that was a commercial I don't know for
what but is this his character Arc I
love you whoa is that a real background
this actually just got it did you wear
yeah uh there's a place right next time
all the places people have died
see you again
race cars we're putting it all together
Greg
and the background what if we didn't
change anything
oh no
beep right now
[Applause]
Mortal Kombat
oh what it's all happening in X-ray
vision
no these are the credits
well that happened
okay so Bobby campo's the name of the
guy you're talking about
yeah I'm curious if I'm gonna go follow
him on Instagram right now yeah Chris
Allen is good
um yeah so we just watched Nation four
and here's what I'll say the people
the people were right
the people were right on this one people
were Wicked right
yeah that was
um I just can't believe we got one two
and three and then this is what followed
was this directed DVD I mean that
honestly no it was clearly in 3D in the
theaters it is clearly made for that
yeah I know you're right you're right
the thing is though it wasn't miserable
to watch and by any means for me what
was it for you
I think uh if we if I if I was at home
by myself I would have turned it off
relatively quick bummer would you no you
would have finished it I think I would
have started cooking dinner
oh she would have just half paid
attention yeah you ever do that or
you're watching something and you're
like man so you just like start I would
have second screened it or started
cooking dinner like I still I love the
premise of these movies so there are
still interesting moments the main
issues I had were that I didn't love the
kills in this one the dialogue was a was
challenging I didn't know or care about
any of the characters
uh and there was no there is no aha
moment like I guess at the end here with
that you hold that
yes I I captain and uh all full of stuff
all right all right what am I pulling up
um go to IMDb
all right let's mouse pad me all right
let's uh what's happening here we're
gonna look up some stuff
I wanna okay type the final
two final destination the final
okay no we got okay here we go is this
one right yep 2009 it's a year I
graduated high school so they got the I
think that their um wardrobes were great
okay the directions
they were accurate the director was
David Ellis all right I'm looking him up
and he also has directed
the likes of uh don't worry I'm gonna
make school go back up what's he known
for go back up he's known for Matrix
Reloaded oh he was a second unit Shark
Night cellular Snakes on a Plane he was
a director okay so he does it's like
some plans like schlocky B movie
entertainment cellular wasn't too bad
have you seen cellular no what is it
it's the one with Chris Evans and he's
trying to save Kim Basinger uh she's
been kidnapped by Jason Statham
okay so where's this like directing
credits okay mainly did stunt work we'll
click on the directing that's kind of
disappointing I mean he's mainly done
stunt work click on the top yeah and
then um Asylum okay
I did Snakes on a Plane before this I
told you that he directed Final
Destination two really
no [__] that is shocking
what was the budget for this one even
though it there was like more it seemed
like it might have been a bigger budget
the budget seemed so tiny during some
parts and with that's where so quickly
hit some of the car and then done all
right type in
final test Nation
production budget all right all right
you got it
okay 20 no that's the that's the gross
okay here we go buy 40 million dollars
that was fun that cost 40 million I
could see it with the 3D and all that
stuff
yeah man yeah wow they got the director
the second one and this is what turned
out that's shocking that's truly
shocking what I need to do something
wrong I have some research what went
wrong with this movie okay hold on
I need to do this I told you what she
was in she was in One Tree Hill and she
was very good in that the flash yep I
was right on about that I'm a brilliant
brilliant person now I need to know
about
okay this other dude what does he do
afterwards Bobby Campo that's the guy
that okay he was in Legally blondes okay
so he didn't work much after this movie
as uh you kind of predicted which is
interesting I really don't feel like
this was his fault but okay and then no
no no there's a lot wrong and then
Michael T Williamson I know from
what he's done like a billion things
yeah I know I know yeah for sure I just
know that I saw him in something
recently that he was very good in oh
species too no Free Willy no
it's none of those oh fences yeah
okay all these things
yeah okay I've seen him in like a
thousand a thousand things
yep good talk yeah good talk good
commissary
well you told me to do this and this so
I'm doing this did I say for you to do
do this no you told me to do this yeah
this is why women are written mad in
these Final Destination movies because
these attitude well I'm just mad because
you got mad first oh that makes sense
yeah um okay let me ask you this
question and I want you to try to answer
it as non-sarcastically as you possibly
can I can do that
[Laughter]
word
what did you like about this movie I
liked the car wash scene because it was
hot yeah yeah way to keep up the
non-sarcasticness
con area Susan Connor I like the car
wash scene I like the scene where um
actress you claim is amazing guys in the
elevator in the escalator Chantel but
I'm telling you she changed her last
name
um I mean maybe she got married and uh
changed her last name yeah I think so
and uh you really like I I think here so
that way we can just uh pull it out and
I don't know
she didn't change her last name it's
still Advanced sand but I don't remember
that being the case uh she's still
attractive yeah she's really cute oh
yeah she's still attractive yeah a full
show she's very good I'm telling you
she's in the boys yeah she's she's uh
butcher's wife yeah yeah the mom but she
is a great actress she is I'm telling
you yes I really think she's super soft
oh my God yeah no I thought she was
great in that show yeah that's why I'm
saying cared about her character a lot I
really feel like we cannot judge any of
these actors based on this because okay
yeah no you're right you're right she's
really good she was in The Flash yeah
she's very good okay I feel bad for her
because in this she genuinely doesn't
seem like she knows what she's doing
okay that's got to be the director or
the the dialogue just type in
okay oh hold on let's go to the trivia
here in the Final Destination I gotta
know the name of the blonde dude because
I know him too okay Nick Sano yeah click
on him what is he in is it 90210 or
what's his deal I've seen him and
something we're uh DC's Legends of
Tomorrow
Hayward no of course he's Nate Haywood
that was so stupid of me oh I told you
it's all the CW people which makes sense
because David Rappaport passes he does
all the CW shows
yeah oh maybe we shouldn't be so
insulting then Krista Allen is the one
that you recognized Krista Allen her
characters literally milk yeah and she
is she's a total MILF she's a stand-up
comic anger management Baywatch she was
in an episode of Friends I guarantee it
and the fact that you can't recall this
no I think you're right but I can't
remember exactly wait you missed it
where
she was anger management no no oh wait
no it said Feast okay yeah I got you I
wish you guys could see what we're
trying to do here did I type
I can't see anything no delete you put
friend
just leave it there all right all right
hit enter
yeah Fable okay so what's the episode
the one where what it was the one where
him remember what the no more Joey dates
Rachel yes right you're gonna tell you
that yeah yeah I know exactly what
you're and then she doesn't look the
same I mean I guess she's younger there
he goes on a I mean it's only been a few
years unless you're saying something
about women just age significantly
within a few years that's kind of mean
and sexist Roxy
women get better as they get older I
couldn't even say that with a straight
face
Jesus everybody knows that men are like
a fine wine and women are like
that is just not a hint of sincerity
there people okay we're going back can
you let's rewind let's go back to the
things you liked about this movie I
liked the 3D it really popped did you
like any character God no they were all
awful the characters were tough in this
one tough what what do you mean tough
you like they were like strong no no it
was like oh man that was tough tough Oh
I thought you were like these were all
stronger no they were tough to like you
know like they really oh no they were
terrible
Michael T Williamson's character was the
most easy to like he was really trying
yeah yeah he was really trying it just
and and it just it felt like just a
series of events just strung together
with no real direction as they were
making this movie their transitions were
bizarre with the flashes like of the 3D
what's happening yeah it just felt
really piecemeal and like although I did
just ask us to talk about what we liked
and I just was not capable of staying on
that I at one point said during the
reaction I'm gonna focus on only the
things that I liked that I don't think I
succeeded for even a minute but the the
they're not a complaint I've had where
I'm like oh I really want them to kind
of feel affected by when a death happens
yes this is especially didn't they would
it was like every next scene was a reset
of just hey we're back to being normal
like right away I I could I just really
couldn't care like blonde boy was sucked
into the pool system gut scores come out
his coin and you guys were all like it's
over it was like what bro that was not
well done okay I'm trying to see we all
know he liked Ted and then he ended up
having no head yeah and then one girl
almost got her head cut off I do think
the uh the car wash scene was actually
well done what happened with the kids of
the MILF
I think they lived I like the car wash
scene too
the lowest rate IMDb thank God
yeah and then they just said this is the
one that Tony Todd's schedule conflicted
with which is a bummer because he I do
like when he's in these
okay I look just just what are you
looking at just type in what went wrong
with Final Destination for
okay okay are we going to the Cesspool
that is Reddit or what do you think in
here there's got to be like
something that happened with what went
wrong with putting this together because
right yeah I mean it would like was it a
different
um was the writers different than any
other movie okay yeah let's start there
it is it's baffling yeah I know
absolutely baffling I Am with You of
what okay we're gonna get down to the
bottom of this okay look all I gotta do
is go to this guy oh and we're just on
Nate Haywood's um thing we were watching
Sarah Lance get married it was really
beautiful I'm sorry okay well yeah like
okay so you know it's directed by the
same guy who directed the second one but
it's written by Eric Bress and Jeffrey
Reddick okay Eric breast okay he wrote
Final Destination two and he wrote The
Butterfly Effect
what I just can't determine
what happened the same team behind two
did this one
that is baffling to me
there's got to be they had a big enough
budget they're the same team they had
quality actors I'm telling you
yeah I I I just can't get over like the
um
I can't get over what happened here
hmm all right there's one last section I
have to check what is it
go to yourself before you wreck yourself
no okay there's no room for jokes now
Roxy go to Wikipedia
oh really there's usually there's like
facts about the production process okay
type the Final Destination okay
all right you good you good an American
3D supernatural horror film all right
development
all right read aloud for the kids at
home if I find something interesting I
will read aloud James Wong was on board
to direct but he was he directed Dragon
Ball Evolution oh man so that scheduling
it to drop out this feels like Dragon
Ball
Evolution so so Ellis accepted because
of the three day Harry said it was Perry
Perry who the [__] is Perry Craig Perry
was a producer okay Craig Perry art the
producer oh the guy who commented he
said he wanted to add depth to the film
instead of just something popping out of
the audience every four minutes
I guess wouldn't that be
not a good reason to do 3D
ah
yes
I'm confused by the sentence he accepted
because of 3D for the 3D Perry said he
wanted to add depth to the film instead
of just something popping out of the
audience every four minutes
can we do an interview where we get
perion to talk to us about it yeah I'm
like I gotta ask you man I just want to
know what happened with this movie
because like so filming the shooting was
it should be done in Vancouver where the
previous ones were filmed but the this
one was shot in New Orleans
okay so they were working in a different
location
there's nothing really here that that
says
when he commented on the video didn't he
say like there's a lot of [__] that went
down or no am I making that up uh I
don't know oh you texted it to me so
let's read it
no yeah let's read it yeah okay let's
read it yeah much less a review and more
of just us
we're just trying to investigate what
the hell happened this is what Kirk
Perry wrote To Us allegedly we I mean I
guess we don't know that it's him but he
says it is this just popped up in my
feed nice having produced all the Final
Destination movies I appreciate your
reaction and in general I agree on
almost all your points there was a lot
of figuring this out as we went along we
also re-shot the ending while beefing up
certain elements throughout all the
sequences you mentioned the budget which
was 23 million back in 1999 when it was
shot but the very advantageous exchange
rate for Canadian currency at the time
we shot in Vancouver brought the budget
to 31 million I do hope you watch the
rest of them outside of fd4 I think
they're all well executed and
entertaining fd5 in particular was a
real return to form it may be my
favorite of the bunch thanks again for
watching okay so he just said I hope you
watch the rest okay so he doesn't like
he was even saying skip four
yeah he says outside of fd4 I think
they're all well executed entertaining
because yeah this one
right off the bat the biggest the
problem that I had with it was the build
up of the sequence of events in the in
the opening NASCAR race because it
didn't
you like the other ones had a very it's
a very simple structure you get to know
the characters beforehand you get
invested and you watch this this Ripple
of effects and then bam the big incident
happens right the premonition moment and
here it was just like rushing through
everything I'm like I have no idea who
these characters are I could care less
there's no tension at all being conveyed
whatsoever and then it felt bogged down
and and CGI gimmicks or even like the
roller coaster event in part three which
must have had CGI there I mean there
were obvious parts of it that felt CGI
but that even felt more tangible that
even felt more real than the NASCAR
stuff that went down which is just in a
crowd you know that is on ground and not
on a removing roller coaster like them
being upside down on the roller coaster
felt way more like oh my God than
anything that happened here and this is
something where I felt this should have
been easier to capture and it just kind
of kept moving at Whiplash Pace without
and it's just felt so empty of emotion
and on every regard like there was such
a lackadaisical quality to the way all
this went down the relationships were
challenged like the lack of chemistry
kind of between the friends where the
two girls Lori and whatever her name was
they didn't seem to like each other that
much and then the couple
um the girl from the boys and her man
they
she says that's my cowboy but like what
was the dynamic there and then the guy
friend of theirs it completes the four
the they didn't care that he died yeah
so that was challenging too yeah I think
that this one just missed the mark from
script to execution
I don't it's hard to blame like one
specific area because it feels like
there was a lot of holes yeah but again
I still Greg I'm not just saying this
because we're doing this reaction I'm
not kidding you I still had an enjoyable
time throughout kind of because the
premise I like and and I did say at one
point I'm curious what happens here I
was never curious yeah it's gonna happen
I was I was you seemed like you were
actually intrigued at times yeah you go
like how are they gonna solve this
what's like you the game was enough for
you at times and for me I was I kept
losing interest as it came it wasn't
even it's so terrible it it's good you
know what I mean it wasn't even it
didn't even quite Broach there where I
felt if if it had at least done that it
was just like questionably bad and it
was kind of breaking my heart because I
thought the third one might have been
the best one so it's a good to go down
with you especially in uh Retros back in
hindsight the third one's my favorite
yeah yeah that one well maybe the fifth
one though like what do you what do you
think obviously they can do differently
than this but what are you hoping to see
is there an opening prediction that you
have like what what kind of scenery we
could be in I mean setting scenario
scenery
it's a beautiful sunny day
here's my favorite thing I liked about
it too is not having not having any bit
of familiarity with it at all I mean I
didn't really like the I I think the the
thumbnail for Final Destination 3 gave
away the roller coaster event right yeah
but Heroes I have no idea what's gonna
happen whatsoever so that was fun
um but I don't know what the
well what the fifth one be it has to be
some type of crazy disaster we've done
plane maybe they could be on set right
something goes wrong on set like it goes
that meta and maybe I don't know people
say the fifth one's amazing so I'm
looking forward to that yeah what are
you
what are your final thoughts on the
final destination for
um
good good yeah oh yeah final thoughts
that yeah I think one thing they had to
nail too was the deaths and they did not
nail the deaths you're right about that
because
I feel like the deaths were designed to
have some moment that had a 3d effect
instead of really packing a true punch
the best death in this one was the car
wash and it wasn't a death
yeah that had the most tangibility and
and uh
like that one you could really feel like
oh this there's something about this I
can latch on because it's relatable we
all go through the car wash and I think
that that's lack that like the dentist
really stood out to us because we I've
been there before you've been there
before roller coaster all that kind of
stands out this was like
sometimes with the race car and the uh
just I don't know it was not as like
poignant yeah good good and the uh
I like the elevator the escalator of
death
it wasn't real
I still thought it would look cool I
thought that was cool yeah but that's
our favorite ones are the ones that
didn't happen
Oh you mean it wasn't real by it was
just a premonition yeah that's true
and I thought they copped out with that
x-ray [__] at the end too yeah kind of
too I know what you mean yeah yeah if
you see them get in them x-ray x-ray but
we did open that way
um okay well that's final destination
form
we're gonna do five please be patient
with me in my little schedule I'm gonna
get back here as soon as I can how's
that cap taste it's not yours right I
don't know not anymore
I think it's your bio freeze man oh it
is my Biofreeze cap yeah is your tongue
turning down
huh no no no no no do you want some no
no I just you want some cap
I'm good I'm all set of the cap um thank
you guys for being here and a special
thank you to somebody right
yeah
the man who
introduced Roxy to the car wash that
person deserves a shout out
okay next time you see Roxy go to a car
wash you make sure to get in line behind
that would have been a good song
prediction take get your car wash day
it's a song
better okay that's a a prediction I
don't know what song you were doing hey
get your car washed today it might be
the same
I don't think it's a song we're losing
steam because we gotta get to our final
destination bed
um no I had said a special shout out
because I was going to give a shout out
to oh yeah special but then you wanted
to shout out the car wash lover because
that is the weirdest you said a lot of
weird stuff here that's easily the
weirdest I did you say often weird
things here and that is easily me never
who we shouting out
I think you should shout out Flav Doran
and you got to do your Boston shout out
let's go flow
Boston no it's just like Flavor Flav but
Flavor Flav nice no it's wicked [__]
Flav it's wicked cool Wicked Flav Wicked
Flav f f is for
foot long Franks at the at Fenway Park
just for family park honestly that was
just a Fenway uh L is for
the
long trip that it takes to get back to
Boston from La it's very long and I'll
be making it soon e is for
extraordinary the whole city is just
extraordinary babe uh V is for um
vagina yeah
it's the best Poon in all the lands
let's go go Boston go Flav that's what
I'm talking about go socks go Flav do
you need to do the face when you do the
Boston accent yeah you got it because
this is the way that it is you know
everyone in Boston looks no because
there's like a cute Boston accent too
what is it it doesn't exist
I always read it on the list of the
ugliest accents and I'm like I can't
deny it that is right uh Flav thanks for
being a patron man and thanks for doing
it up with us
you know what I mean yeah I'm already uh
yeah you're ready to go oh my God you
just yawn.com yeah I did I'm ready my
link Cuisine Pizza you gotta pack yeah
okay yeah my final destination has come
until it's yours to an end we will see
you guys for the fifth one at some point
until then like comment subscribe all
that good good thanks for sitting
through this one with us and we'll see
you next time
foreign